The story of a penny originated from the first American Mint established in the United States in 1792. The Mint made these
a penny coin, plus other coins, including two hairs, one hair, half hair, and one
"Mysterious coins", we will mention later.
The penny coins of these new societies are made of 100% pure copper.
However, there are two forces together to ensure that this (100% pure copper) does not last long: the value of copper
It has risen, and at the same time, because of inflation, the purchasing power of a penny has decreased.
This caused the Mint to reduce the amount of copper in a penny, starting from only 100% to 95%.
Eventually dropped to only 5% copper and 95% zinc.
Still, in 2006, the value of metal in the old 1 cent coin exceeded
1 cent, suddenly, the value of these coins "dead" is higher than the value of "living", people start to refine the metal in 1 cent
Used to sell money.
In a reasonable and efficient world, the story of a penny should end here.
The government should see that it is not cost-effective to make a penny, and it is happy to see that the people are blocking 1 cent.
It is recycled.
However, the US government has banned people from melting American coins while continuing
Make a million-dollar coin every year.
This action idiot spends 1.8 cents in the United States to make a 1 cent coin.
But even a penny coin is made from something that represents their true value, such as plastic or lint.
This will not solve the most fundamental problem of a penny: A penny is not good for the people and the economy.
The reasons are as follows:
The role of money is to make it easier for people to buy things.
A store keeper has something and you want that stuff. We are not bargaining like a savage.
We will use money as an intermediary for exchange.
In order for us not to pay the value of matter, the coin must be divided into different values.
But money will not be divided forever. Because the value of the money representative is too small,
No one can buy anything and no one will take care of it. This brings us back to a penny.
In the former society, a penny can buy things, but now it can't. Today, if you want to spend it
For a penny coin, you have to think about it.
For example, try to buy 20 dollars, but use two thousand penny coins, weighing a total of 11 pounds.
So you have to use the change to use these penny coins.
However, there is no tax added in the US market price (not like civilization
Country), no one can multiply the price by 8.875% in his head, you can't change your change
Be prepared before you go to the toll booth.
These penny coins that you will deal with after you find the real price of your goods.
On average, each money transaction is extended by 2 seconds, which is not the value of your time.
It is not the value of the time of the person who is lined up behind you. This is why normal people do not manage change,
The "culprits" who often count a penny of coins are those who have not done better.
If you want to spend a penny coin but don't waste someone else's time
You may be able to find a machine that receives them.
good luck. The vending machine does not need a penny coin, washing machine or
The toll booth or parking meter does not use this coin, or any other machine: because they are not worth it.
The effort of counting, storing and transporting.
In fact, there is a machine that will receive a penny coin: Coinstar--one is ignored by society
Machine, except that it will only give you money that is already yours, while
Also charge a 10% fee.
The disadvantage of drawing a penny is that they are often discarded in cans and have a dead mass for the economy.
After their short, useless lives, they failed in their only job: it lived purely for economic transactions.
The impact of its existence is just the opposite: it is the dead weight of every transaction.
They must be abolished.
However, you may think that without a penny, the value of the item will not rise, and the income of the charity will not fall?
Will not.
New Zealand abolished their penny coins, as did Australia. Neither Finland nor the Netherlands
A cent euro coin. But that might be a penny. The euro is too small and too annoying.
The reason is gone.
These countries are rounded to the nearest five cents when trading, and they have no experience.
Price increases or charitable donations declined.
At the same time, the United States has also abolished coins and has not had any trouble.
Remember the "mystery coin" in front of the film? This is half a penny. Have you seen one recently? you
of course not. It was abolished in 1857 because it was too worthless.
But when half a penny is deactivated, it’s worth more than today’s, so it’s possible
A list of coins that can be revoked today can be added to a few.
This has the last, unreasonable reason why you can't abolish a penny coin.
Everyone loves Lincoln -- at least, most people love him. After the history of the Statue of Liberty and the United States,
The United States really has Lincoln - a coin of one inch size.
But eliminating a penny coin will not erase Lincoln from history.
Lincoln and his monument will still be on the five-dollar bill that will not be eliminated.
At the same time, if you think that retiring a coin with a presidential head is unpatriotic or inhuman,
Please allow me to pick you up a small organization called the US military.
Here, they have already abandoned a penny coin at their overseas bases and automatically rounded them up to
The last five cents.
In the morning and evening, those who are most enthusiastic about Lincoln have to give up a penny coin: they
The price is lower than the price at which they are made, they waste people's time, they can't be used as money,
At the same time, because of the fact that they are getting less and less money each year because of inflation, several other problems have been severed.
Sorry for Lincoln, but it's really time to stop a penny coin.